hey guys I'm Polina and Game of Thrones
season 8 is finally here almost the
first episode airs this Sunday but if
you have not had the time to re-watch
the last seven seasons maybe because you
were too busy pre watching all of the
Marvel movies ahead of endgame and you
can't do both because your children miss
you Alan
then you might be feeling a little lost
right now hopefully you've checked out
our video series and podcast Westeros
weekly which digs deep into these
questions you have about Game of Thrones
please subscribe to that on iTunes to
keep up with all of our Game of Thrones
coverage and get it way earlier than it
comes out on YouTube okay so now let's
help you sort out all the characters
prophecies crazy fan theories that you
need to know about for this final season
first up what happened quick reminder
Season 7 left off with all the major
players gearing up for war with the
White Walkers
Daenerys John Tyrion and their crew they
all meet up with Cersei Jaime and Euron
Greyjoy at King's Landing forming a very
delicate alliance it's a lot like us and
emergency awesome we're not gonna fight
to the death yet so then team Danny
heads back to Winterfell to prepare
their forces for the incoming attack but
no no no it turns out Cersei is not
planning to actually help wipe out the
White Walkers she lies she sent you're
on to retrieve the golden company from
Essos so they can kill whichever of
Circe's enemies are left standing after
the kinga denied does his damage and if
you're not impressed by the golden
company remember these two words murder
elephants yeah they got those
okay so Jaime's all disgusted and leaves
his sister's side to head north
choosing the good guys over his sister
and mother of his unborn as-of-yet unmei
be unexist --nt child because remember
she lies all right over in Winterfell
Sansa Arya and bran are all together
Samwell Tarly arrives and gets the
latest costume brand about Jon Snow's
true heritage as both these guys now
know Jon Snow is not the bastard son of
Eddard Stark his real name is actually
Aegon his face Targaryen the legitimate
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and Ned sister
Lyanna Stark he thus Targaryen if you
will what's that you don't you don't
want to do that fine he's at argh argh
you like that that's what you get now
thar dark together they realize John
probably the direct heir to the Iron
Throne just in time for John and his
aunt an heiress to put their mouths on
each other and hug a lot you know sex of
course there's the fact that brand does
know everything and could just warg in
and tell them to quit with all that
gross Ness but he's probably still
traumatized from the last time he peeped
on some incest he freaked on and you
know he doesn't need another trip down
memory tower okay and on top of all that
Theon you remember him the Ironborn
without the iron horn used to go by reek
now he sits to take a leak you remember
he's done a quest to save his sister
from his uncle you're on a CAFO Russell
Crowe
also there is uh Melisandre she's the
red witch whose necklace has the power
of Botox she may or may not return to
Westeros to die she's alluded to that
before and oh yeah the White Walkers a
night king who just tore through
Eastwatch and the wall with the help of
their very own puff the ratchet dragon
and it looks like they're heading for
Winterfell next so that's where the
major players are at the end of season
seven but what are the big questions and
theories to keep in mind heading into
season eight no sure it's very easy to
forget some of this because you know the
end of the world is coming and there's a
bunch of battles between humans and
White Walkers but reminder this show is
called Game of Thrones so once all those
battles are done who's gonna take the
Iron Throne
while Cersei does currently sit on it if
she's somehow defeated and overthrown or
maybe she gets a bad case of Arya throat
she doesn't have any surviving children
to take over so while others may seek
the claim there would be a lot of
legitimacy to the previous ruling houses
and not just the Targaryen
technically the Baratheon stew and now
with Gendry back and bastard's becoming
kings in the north then he might
actually have a chance but of course the
much bigger claim is probably between
John and Danny and you thought finding
out you're related to the biggest strain
you could put on a romance now they both
have claim to the point each heir if
season eight doesn't have a lot of
scenes taking place in the office of a
westerosi couples counselor I'm gonna be
very worried about these two now another
question to keep in your noggin is who's
going to be the real final threat to our
unlucky Starks is it
Cersei or the night king like yes the
night king has his very own dead eye
white dragon but Game of Thrones has
always been more focused on
interpersonal conflicts than an
unstoppable army of snow zombies
which by the way is why we will never
win in a war with Alaska it actually
wouldn't be that crazy if the night King
goes down in the first half of the
season and then we're left with what
george RR martin says is his favorite
part of the story the struggle for the
Iron Throne but yeah speaking of the
night King he's got his own questions
swirling around his spiky dome for
instance who is he really
there's a popular fan theory that bran
Stark is the night King have been time
Ward into the very first white Walker
created by the children of the forest
you can actually check out Eric's video
for more evidence on that theory but
aside from who he is
we also still don't really know what he
wants what is motivating his war on
humanity is he out to kill someone in
particular maybe take out some children
of a forest
who knows maybe he's just like me and he
wants the world to be a winter
wonderland of forever Christmas it'd be
delightful
we don't know by the way in the most
recent episode of Westeros weekly we go
into a bunch of guesses about what could
be motivating this guy if that is
there's any motivation at all and he's
not just some sort of agent of chaos
like the Joker was in The Dark Knight
though he definitely looks more like
he'd be in a band with Jared Leto's
Joker dude that would be so sick frozen
clown posse they killed a ward tour
literally and then reanimated everybody
I don't know music next question is
Brandon getting stronger or is he at the
beginning of his three-eyed Raven
puberty
last we heard we know he has the power
to inhabit the mind of someone in the
past and make them into a human Pokemon
we also know he can be heard by people
in the past like young Eddard Stark at
the Tower of joy
that's something he still might do more
of like in the theory that he was the
one that sometime in the past was
whispering those sweet sweet nothings
into the mad Kings ear and actually made
him said Mad King that's why you got to
be careful with short he's whispering in
your ear things get hot real fast just
look at Ned Stark's dad and brother
it certainly fired them up but yeah bran
might even have more stuff we haven't
seen him do yet he was once told that he
would never walk again but he would fly
sure he's like Morgan to some birds but
come on we definitely got to see at
least some hovering through the air or a
few feet off the ground at least high
enough so his legs aren't like bumping
into stuff another questions when it
comes to killing the White Walkers is
the prophecy of azor Ahai also known as
the prince that was promised as legend
has it the last time the world del
with the long night it was azor Ahai who
liberated humanity and same legend has
it that he'll be resurrected to save the
world once more like some badass spring
loving Jesus wait isn't one of these
episodes supposed to come out on Easter
I think I just figured out how to get my
grandma to start talking to me again
anyway
supposedly this promise warrior will
also wield a powerful blade called
light bringer that has the power to
bring light right into your jugular now
the biggest mystery about this is that
it's likely that whomever is gonna take
on this mantle of a soar high is
probably someone we already know so
Vegas odds are certainly pointing to Jon
Snow but it could be almost anyone we
even have a video saying how it could be
Jaime Lannister check that out on your
next extra-long bathroom break also
reminder even Stannis Baratheon thought
he might be the prince that was promised
but ya know killing your daughter
doesn't tend to go hand in hand with
being the hero that will save us all
ironically though killing a loved one
actually is part of the prophecy it's
claimed that as or ahyes weapon of
Lightbringer needs to be forged with a
loving wife's heart in the past azor
Ahai needed to kill his wife miss Anissa
in order for his sword to bring the
light and bring the fight so if that
part of the prophecy needs to happen
that would mean our hero has to kill
their lover so either John has to kill
Danny or Jaime has to kill Cersei or
because the prophecy is actually
gender-neutral very progressive the
murders can happen in the other
direction too okay another prophecy to
keep in your head is about Cersei back
when Cersei was a little jerk she went
to visit some lady in the woods named
Maggie the frog who like chance the
rapper has really dug collaborations
with the future some of her predictions
for Cersei were very sweet like she
would marry a king which came true but
then she also predicted that you know
all her children would die young so the
questions to keep in mind about this
prophecy one it didn't cover what would
happen with this potential fourth child
that Cersei claims she's pregnant with
so what's gonna happen there and - the
books contain a final part of the
prophecy not seen on the show where a
little Miss the Frog claims that Cersei
will be killed by the valonqar
which translates to little brother in
Valyrian though she didn't say your bow
encar just the valonqar
a valonqar so it could apply to Jaime
or Tyrion or anyone who is a younger
brother technically either way it sounds
like Cersei will probably be going down
one last time at the hands of a brother
now the real question is how many people
she and her murder elephants will take
down along the way okay in the last
major question you got to keep in mind
when you're watching what's gonna happen
with arias hit list as she's evolved
into a face swapping assassin though not
technically an official faceless man
she's managed to cross quite a few names
off her old Hitler's some significant
remaining names include Cersei Lannister
and both Clegane brothers if we're to
believe the Frog then Circe's fate seems
already sealed but Arya might have a
shot of revenge against either of the
claw games though it's kind of up for
debate whether or not Sandor the Hound
Clegane is still really on her list and
she did have the chance to kill him once
before instead she just left him there
and personally I'd rather see the claw
gains deal with each other themselves by
finally giving us the long hyped plug in
bull Gregor versus Sandor Mountain
versus hound head popper versus chicken
eater one of those is more badass than
the other but still fingers crossed we
finally see this happen now looking
forward to Season eight just in case
you're dead on the inside and somehow
you are not hyped enough here's where
you can be pumped for one of the biggest
moments we're looking forward to the
season is the Battle of Winterfell which
will probably go down in season eight
episode three and is set to be the
biggest action sequence of the entire
series in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly co-executive
producer Bryan cogman said this final
face-off between the army of the Dead
and the army of the living is completely
unprecedented and relentless and a
mixture of genres even within the battle
I'm hoping that includes like slapstick
comedy and here's something by the way
it sounds epic
this also backs up the idea that I had
earlier that the threat of the white
walkers could be dealt with as early as
the 3rd episode granted there's a lot
that would go into this like whether the
good guys figure out how to make enough
filler and steel weapons to go around or
that prince that was promised prophecy
he has to go really fast and happen in
the first three episodes of the season
oh but are you saying that that's not
hype enough okay how about the fact that
the night king might bring back
previously dead characters they already
got a zombie dragon zombie giant a horde
of
soldiers but there's nothing like
sprinkling in the psychological warfare
of having to wreak ill your loved ones a
big example this could be Lady
Stoneheart the reincarnated Catelyn
Stark from the books she was left out of
the show so far but in the books Lady
Stoneheart is just consumed by rage
seeking vengeance against those
responsible for the death of her and Rob
that would be insane but even if it
doesn't happen how about all the other
Starks that are buried below Winterfell
they've got that whole tomb of the
undead soldiers just waiting to come
into play wait that's not hype enough
for you either maybe you're a little
less into epic zombie battles are more
into caddy and a personal drama between
ex best friends well get ready for a
bunch of that like when Samwell Tarly
reunites with his friend Jon Snow who's
actually a Targaryen who is hooking up
with a naughty Targaryen who just burned
his father and brother alive ooh
indirect aggression or how about when
you're on a Redemption arc and you feel
like maybe you are a pretty good guy and
then you reunite with that kid that you
crippled whoo oh by the way has since
become an all-knowing God level beam
drama okay guys you're all caught up on
everything you need to know going into
season eight but if there are any other
questions you have about the season feel
free to hit me up in the comments or on
instagram at Phillip Malina or Twitter
at fimo and again check out our Westeros
weekly podcast feed where all of our
comprehensive Game of Thrones coverage
the breakdowns everything they'll all be
available before they come out on
YouTube oh also if you're gonna tweet
your questions make sure to use that
hashtag Westeros weekly and we might
answer it on our Q&A show finally do not
forget to enter our death pool on guest
the throne Calm look up the Westeros
weekly group there and then mark down
who you think is gonna die we'll be
giving shout outs on the Q&A show to the
people who's brackets are doing the best
and the winners gonna get a little prize
all right guys I need to go repent for a
lot of terrible things I just said in
this video peace
[Music]